hi I'm Mike Zimmer from FX guide.com for
wired rogue one came from an idea from I
limbs own John Knoll and just as with
the original Star Wars in 1977 John
non-attainment LM used rogue one to push
the boundaries of visual effects
especially in the area of digital humans
while the film rogue one is in
contention for its own visual effects
Oscar the team at ILM have already won
recognition from the Academy with a 2017
saitec award the Oscars are awarded by
the Academy of Arts and Sciences and the
science and technology awards are not
for a single film but rather for a
contribution to the crowd normally
spanning years in this case for people
who were at ILM have been honored for
the development of the ILM facial
pipeline actually the facial pipeline
that gives you grand moff tarkin started
much earlier when Karen bard and Michael
copper vos actually got together to work
on the faces for Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Michael actually had worked on
Rango as a CG character animator so he
kind of knew what the artists were after
while Kieran is a kind of self-confessed
maths guy now teenage turtles was
incredibly complex and these guys were
really pushed completely had their hands
full so when ILM was awarded another big
character film Warcraft a second team
had to be put together to service the
faces needed for that film in this case
it was Brian Cantwell and Paige Warner
these two teams kind of worked
separately though sharing work until
they finished those films and then came
together for the new Star Wars films so
how does a Tarkin or any other Star Wars
character face pipeline work well as
with any character it starts with the
design of the character and then an
actor that's going to drive it so in the
case of Mars from the force awakens they
had to come up with the character and
then an actor who would drive that and
that after then needs to be scanned a
couple of different ways so for example
if I wanted to be a Star Wars character
I would need to have two separate scans
done the first in a complex light stage
which will give a very high resolution
picture of my skin and a kind of model
of how my skin would react under
different types of life here I'm
pictured in the USC ICT light stage I'm
in a sort of sister rig to the one that
the rogue one team used down at Oh toy
in LA to scan actor guy Henry after the
light stage guy then has to have another
scan this time in a Medusa rig vetted by
ILM s sister company Disney research in
Zurich we visited them as well
you can theoretically make up pretty
much any digital expression your life by
adding and sort of subtracting or
producing combinations of scans of blend
shapes from this fair's library now we
need guy to actually go and set and
deliver his real performance I will tell
him as his patience with your
misadventures has been rewarded with a
weapon that could bring a swift end any
actor who's actually been filmed this
way is been constantly filmed by four
little cameras that are on a head
mounted rig but nevertheless they can
move around a lot quite naturally on set
and this is where the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle team that face team I
mentioned earlier had a really brilliant
breakthrough a few years ago you see
what the computer tries to do is match
up what they're getting from guy on set
with what guy did when he was sitting
quietly in the Madhu Surrey the team
then invented a thing called snaps over
which goes through and does tiny little
movements to all of the parts of the
face now the team over on Warcraft was
so impressed with this idea that they
saw a way that they could use it and
actually magnify the effect and they got
this snaps over to do a lot more heavy
lifting on Warcraft and thus when the
two teams came together they had a
really powerful face pipeline
okay so jump to the present day in rogue
one you have now this very accurate
digital version of what guy Henry's did
on set very very faithful to his
performance of course we don't have a
digital Tarkin yet and here the model is
at ILM were very lucky because the actor
Peter Cushing who played Tarkin had a
plaster life cast done of him in the mid
80s and this was something along with of
course digital reference that allowed
them to produce a very accurate model of
his space now you might think that's it
right now all we have to do is
target the information from guy Henry's
digital performance to this digital head
place it perhaps on the body of a guy
Henry and we're done unfortunately it's
not that simple and so this is where the
animators at ILM have to jump in to
deliver a talk and with Peters
performance not guys so even though guy
may produce a great performance that
sounds and looks a lot like Tucker it's
Peters interpretation of the character
that you're going to see on screen
thanks to this work that's done by the
island animators the original plans for
this stage from the pivot and it doesn't
stop there of course with modern
techniques and modern styles the film
rogue one isn't Litton shot the same way
as the original new hope in fact gareth
edwards the director likes to himself
grab the camera and film in a much more
documentary style so what happen is that
the team in Ireland had to render a
digital Tarkin that looks and feels like
we remember Tarkin even though he's lit
differently and of course a completely
synthetic character and it's a
remarkable achievement
[Music]
the original pants with his station I
couldn't say well don't forget subscribe
for more behind the scenes action
I'm Mike say more for a while
may the force be with us
[Music]